a battle continues in court over a
troubled apartment complex while people
living there say they had to struggle to
stay warm last night it is a story the 8
news now investigators have been
following closely Vanessa Murphy has an
update from what one mother and child
are going through
it's just dark
dark
that's how Amy Irwin says she and her
son got through the night Thursday after
the utilities bill for the Apex
Apartments wasn't paid and the Heat and
power were shut off we slept in the cold
like he was buried under like three or
four blankets last night in Pat's lungs
like long underwear the whole nine yards
I was sitting out here with a scarf and
a hat on a large area in the unit
they're living in doesn't have carpet
the property is operating without a
license according to Clark County's
website the county is suing the owner's
california-based pro-residential
pointing to crime like homicides
shootings and drug dealing and other
dangerous conditions since the lawsuit
was filed in April of 2022 tenants have
been evicted the 8 news now
investigators uncovered the owners
collected covid-19 relief money and most
units are empty a judge giving the
owners chance after chance to clean the
property up Irwin says she was here when
the new owners took over nearly two
years ago she and other tenants said
that's when things took a turn for the
worse she admits she hasn't paid rent
for months but tells us she has a
pending application for rental
assistance do you think Apex will say
she's squatting yes she says she was
working but lost her job she starts a
new one next week you seem optimistic I
have to be because every day above
ground is a good day and I have an 11
year old I have to prove to him that I
can make it through it it's me and him
against the world so we'll do it just
kind of got to fake it till you make it
Erwin says if the county would help her
find new housing at an affordable rate
she would go people are like why don't
you move if it's a horrible area do you
have three times the rent and you just
kind of fly under the radar and hope it
doesn't get bad hope the Electric's on
she admits Thursday night was tough
especially since Friday marks a special
moment turned 11 today and so he spent
the night before his birthday
in the cold in the dark and said Mama am
I going to have power for my birthday
tomorrow and I'm like I hope so
she says the power came back on before
11 A.M Friday the battle over the
lawsuit continues the next court date is
set for January 10th Vanessa Murphy 8
News Now
Vanessa reached out to the owners did
not receive a response at this time now
NB energy tells us the company would not
shut off electricity if the temperature
is 15 degrees or lower so last night
would not have apparently met that
requirement